[Music]
yo
mama sorry dr mama how do you think this
year's gonna go for these new students
i'm psyched you're excited for the first
day of school
why is everybody so rich are you ready
for my party saturday night i got dj
khaled's baby to make you a playlist
it's okay time out what is up with these
kids
in attendance will be the governor of
california
max dad you look amazing your hair's
fire my dad's also coming i don't care
about your dad spencer
i just care about zach and kelly
we all want these new kids to feel
welcome let's see what happens
can we talk did you just sit backwards
in a chair wow i've never seen anyone do
that in real life
it's not gonna work unless we get to
know them you only know how bayside
works for kids like you
hot kids privileged kid privileged kids
[Applause]
break out cut bayside so i finally felt
like i belong
this place is magic again oh damn i love
magic hey max actually i ordered cheese
on mine take a look in your pocket
does this place ever stop being weird um
one two three
the old gang back together again
[Music]
will you go to dinner with me stop
eavesdropping we're not we're the
bayside a cappella group
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
ah bayside
[Music]
you're the man coach when i grow up i
want to be just like you a single
childless adult who parties with kids
you